all right welcome everybody we are
seeing in the White House press briefing
room a very zoomed in a lectern right
now but standing by for the start of yet
another White House coronavirus press
briefing my expectation as these have
been becoming more and more dystopian I
would expect a ton of lies a ton of
deception whoa we've got someone's nose
right there very very close
and we are going to presumably see
bragging about the visit from Andrew
Cuomo today Governor Andrew Cuomo of New
York coming to the White House just uh I
guess an hour ago to meet with Donald
Trump hour and a half ago or something
like that we will see bragging about
that um despite a continued plateau of
absolutely horrible death numbers Donald
Trump will continue to sort of pretend
as though victory has already taken
place and we've won this thing despite
the fact that it is absolutely not the
case and we're going to go through all
of those numbers we're going to have all
of it today so that's essentially the
set up the press conferences over time
becoming more deceptive more dishonest
more dystopian trump's throwing more and
more tantrums as well and we're going to
go through a little bit of that
momentarily welcome if you're just
joining me on twitter twitch youtube and
facebook seth Barham has sent the super
chat already and says david just want to
give you props on your Chomsky segment
very well put and hard to refute
logically also our friend Frankie mink
has subscribed on YouTube hey Frank hope
you're doing well fat Frank has been a
multiple time guest on the David Pakman
show very much appreciate the support
the latest numbers official numbers of
course coronavirus cases surpassing 2.5
million globally officially the real
number is somewhere between listen at
this point we could say it's probably at
least two times the official number up
to 20 or 30 times the official number we
just don't know and I'll have a story
about that tomorrow the death number 177
thousand
you look at some graphs so we can look
at how that trend line is going where is
the one I am looking for daily cases as
you can see seem to have plateaued the
same number of new cases yesterday as we
saw roughly on March 31st so remember
the peak is not really a peak it's a
plateau it's currently been lasting at
least 21 days roughly here in the United
States the official case number is now
eight hundred and fifteen thousand we
have surpassed forty five thousand
deaths the the trend line is not good
again remember Donald Trump is
pretending like we've won but as you can
see here we are here in a plateau that
goes back roughly to April first it's
it's been 21 days we expect that it
would be somewhere between 21 and 28
days of plateau before you start to see
a decline maybe more concerning is the
fact that the deaths are still coming
fast and furious yesterday 1939 but if
you look at the numbers today we're
already at almost 2600 deaths today and
it's only 5:20 p.m. Eastern Time I
believe these reset at zero at midnight
GMT which is 8:00 p.m. Eastern so we've
still got oh boy something weird going
on with my hair what is that I showered
earlier today because my schedule is all
whacked but something very strange
almost like a leech looked like a leech
was crawling out of my hair there that
was weird
we will likely see this number hit 2,700
2,800 the numbers are really really bad
one other note as we stand by for the
Trump coronavirus press briefing looks
like we're at least 15 minutes away if
not longer the most important sort of
forefront in this fight is testing okay
we now the few we don't have a vaccine
that's going to be available widely in
the next year treatments we are trying
them clora Quinn's not working we're
trying room des aveer there's dozens of
things being tested all we really have
right now is social distancing and
testing they are lying uncontrollably
about testing Donald Trump said
yesterday every 10 days I'm sorry every
week we're doubling our test capacity
just look at the numbers this is kovin
tracking dot-com if you look at the last
week you'll see the tests range between
137 and 167 a day if you look at the
week before you will see that the tests
ranged between 129 and 162 we are not
doubling testing every week they are
lying if we do not increase testing -
now I'm gonna give you three levels
we've got to get to 500,000 tests a day
minimum to even have a conversation
about doing anything we probably need at
least a million a day and some models
say we need up to 22 million a day 22
million a day would let you test the
population roughly every two weeks dr.
Burks already said with an RNA test you
won't get those numbers you need an
antigen test which we don't currently
have this is the most important
dashboard after looking at cases and
deaths it's this it's not the models
it's not you know whatever it is Donald
Trump is pointing to this is it and as
you can see they are lying daily about
those numbers let me say a huge thank
you to our twitch viewers we started on
twitch this year we're only nine months
in on twitch and we've accumulated
almost thirty-four thousand followers
there anybody with an Amazon Prime
subscription can subscribe for free with
twitch Prime we get paid it costs you
nothing a few people I want to thank our
adjusting D winters Comstock rocker
political puppy vermin supreme stream
Thor boys 66 and Eric Rothschild all of
whom have either contributed or signed
up in some way over on Twitch let's now
go to some of your Super chats and see
what's on people's minds
these are YouTube super chats you can
get your message up up on the screen
using the super chat function but
remember always like and subscribe as
you enter the stream Charlie says Trump
be like my ratings are amazing Super
Bowl level ratings the best ratings
I don't care about ratings though yeah
everything's they could incoherent right
now consider that in the last 24 hours
Donald Trump told us things are so good
that tons of states will soon be open
but things are so bad that he needs to
suspend all immigration to the United
States something no president has done
before wait a second if everything's
fine and things are going so well why do
we need the unprecedented measure of
suspending immigration to the United
States it's not really making sense it's
not really making sense let's see here
most CFX blood says want me to make you
a post-apocalyptic mask you know I have
enough masks right now so I appreciate
it but maybe someone else doesn't
currently have one because I I'm good on
masks a couple of people in the audience
set masks to me Lee Douglas says could
you discuss your favorite animal and why
you know I I don't have a favorite
animal I'd really have to think about
that Shawn Tedrow or Teatro says thanks
for all the hard work I try to make it
through more and more of these live
streams but I usually have to turn it
off before becoming frustrated I feel
your pain Ben Beus Inc says thank you so
much for all of your great work do you
have any news sources you recommend to
subscribers and viewers you know I try
to avoid that because there's no way to
really do something comprehensive and no
news source is like always right so I
try to avoid lists of media outlets with
total peace and love I say that rat
cracker says who was involved in the
debate that you moderated I am unable to
say at this point in time but you will
see very very soon Sarah s says do you
watch or have you heard of China InFocus
NTD
I have not I have not but I am now
watching season 3 of Souda on Netflix
which I have to tell you it's probably
the best current show on TV and I try to
avoid being hyperbolic when it comes to
that type of thing but it is arguably
the best show on TV right now is this
Bret Baier and why does he look so
physically
odd and why is he at the press briefing
I wonder but is something about Brett
Bayer here looks really strange doesn't
it like what would it's a very strange
way to stand I'm not I'm having trouble
making uh making sense out of it okay
Trevor R says Dave do you plan on
debating any personalities you know
taking an ever Biden stance probably not
owl aquatic says Senate passed the four
hundred and eighty billion at 5:15 brag
session yes Trump will be bragging about
that as well
Nosa vets gaming says David do you see
Cuomo emerging as a major player on the
left after all this passes in the same
vein as Rudy post-911
it's possible it's possible you know
these are such unique circumstances that
we really don't know what to expect
that's the reality
Paul JM says hey David what did Trump
mean yesterday would the Second
Amendment and Virginia Trump believes
that people's guns are being confiscated
in Virginia and he's urging Second
Amendment activists to liberate the
state if you've never heard if those
aren't double entendre z' for violence
then I don't know what are a she'd
Everton says how was the recording
yesterday very strong and you will know
more about that soon nasty questions
says you know the only reason I'm here
thank you for articulating what we are
all feeling and thinking thank you so
much a rich ropa thak says after putting
on the masks should you run around
saying somebody stop me and give wedgies
to people a richer oh you've really got
to up your game a retro I think tries to
be provocative he's been doing it for
years but I I don't know that you're
succeeding my friend I do appreciate the
support though Miz Smith says awesome
show spreading your name as it is an
honest straightforward commentary thanks
for what you do a thank you so much I
really do appreciate that let me say
thank you to a couple of really great
people
Joseph Finn has just grabbed a
membership on my website join pakman.com
and a mod lawton has also
a membership at join pakman.com and is
new member number two I'm limiting my
membership mentions to just one per
stream it's a minute in a three hour
stream so I'm gonna do that right now we
are mostly funded by our viewers that
means you whether you're watching on
Twitter twitch Facebook or YouTube the
most direct way to support us where we
keep the largest slice of every dollar
is my website join pakman.com so
consider grabbing a membership there by
any reasonable standard it should take
you under a minute to sign up and that
coupon code there twenty twenty now will
save you sixty-six percent off of a
membership so we're talking about two
dollars a month or only a dollar eighty
a month if you pay for the entire year
at once and every one of you is going to
get a thank you every single person who
signs up get it gets a thank you we have
a modest goal of twenty-five website
members we've done much better before I
have faith that we may be able to to do
it today and oh and people are asking
what is the slice so we pay two point
nine percent to process payments on our
website I can assure you patreon twitch
YouTube all of them take way more than
two point nine percent they all they all
tell us we can't say how much what I can
tell you is two point nine percent is
way below I think I'm being clear with
everybody so in any case I will thank
everybody who signs up I also want to
say thanks to lefty twelve thousand and
a hodge Elton as well as Effie and AJ
London no matter
oh oh also pan puke and Tammy girl will
be three gaming and Stefon row have
signed up on Twitch as well as digi Oh
Orca heart Joe ah geez DJ pastime jf
Callen names taken I'm having I'm having
trouble parsing some of these and quite
frankly Brett Bayers weird stance is
actually one of the big reasons why I'm
having so much trouble really really
distracting me
okay other super chats coming in rat
cracker says thoughts on destiny coming
out as a right-winger didn't see it
couldn't comment can't independently
verify JH wh says how do you guys keep
up with this workload the workload has
been high during the during coronavirus
it's actually crazy it's they're very
very long days and we amazingly we've
done it all in the midst of YouTube
revenue being down 35% we're doing it
all without cutting hours that's the
crazy thing that's my goal and the
commitment I've made to my employees
which is why it's just so tremendous for
lack of a better term when folks you
know grab memberships memberships or
make a patreon pledge or whatever the
case may be okay Paul JM says was the
debate between Sam cedar and creationist
cat it was not very good question but it
was not a rat cracker says when are you
going to debate ben shapiro anytime he
wants scott phillips says how dangerous
is it that fox has been driving
misguided support for a premature
reopening of the economy very dangerous
I live in rural Virginia and noticing
increasingly large public gatherings
without masks listen there is no
statistical basis on which the the
economy can be reopened okay if you look
at the case numbers we are in the peak
the peak is not one day the peak is long
if you look at the death numbers they
are staggering and today it's about
2,500 if you look at the testing numbers
we are not increasing testing we have
tested roughly the same number of people
this week as we did last week as the
week before despite the fact that Donald
Trump insists we are doubling tests
every single week these are lies until
you can increase testing and you see
cases decline there's no conversation to
even have it sucks but what we know from
the 1918 flu pandemic is that the short
term benefit of opening up is far lower
than the long term benefit of remaining
closed as long as you have to or as long
as you should I think a better said so
you know it's it's painful
the
economics in the short-term are ugly but
over the long-term
it's the right thing to do and I don't
even think we really have much to
discuss
until the numbers start to turn around
testing needs to go way up cases and
deaths need to come way way down let me
say thank you to Murray Dutton who has
just made a pledge on patreon but I'm
counting it I'm counting it towards our
goal of 25 website members everything
counts patreon counts and website
memberships count today oh and someone's
telling me my website is actually down
that shouldn't be the case we've
dramatically scaled up the power of the
website no it looks like the website is
fine it may be user error which I say
with total peace and love without
offending anybody but there may be a
user error component but it looks like
the website is is working beautifully
beautifully okay Justin Olson says David
does the show foul to humanize
Palestinians absolutely environmental
coffeehouse says did Trump really say
that hundreds of Governors are calling
him I didn't see that I didn't see that
I have a bet going and I need the answer
I don't have it in me to sit through to
listen through yesterday's all over
again
Trump did say that his actions saved
billions of people which is weird
because only 330 million live in the
u.s. so that math is fuzzy to me for
sure but no I'm not aware of Trump
saying that that there are hundreds of
Governors calling him let me say thanks
to John Sam and skillet queso for
subscribing with twitch prime as well as
octo progams
all really great people other super
chats coming in Nero stream says our
other US territories such as Puerto Rico
getting the same support as other states
I don't believe they are and I think
that's why we don't hear them mention by
the task force unknown prodigy says I'm
signed up with twitch and YouTube give
me a shout-out absolutely hey by the way
have you guys noticed that Donald Trump
sometimes gets confused between
giving someone a shout-out and calling
someone
calling someone out of course being
saying something's doing something bad
shout out being a positive thing Trump
often you can tell he's he's talking
about shout outs but he's calling people
out and it's really weird and kind of
awkward okay Danny Thompson says the
Washington Post has a recent article
article about three brothers from
Minnesota being responsible for at least
five different state protests they are
pro-gun to an extreme
yeah the pro-gun movement has a lot of
overlap with the protesters the
anti-vaxxer movement has a lot of
overlap with the protesters Tea Party
types it's the usual suspects that are
the majority of the protesters right now
Dion Vargas asks how can I start a
channel like yours step one record
videos step two upload them step three
keep doing it that's the start there's
so many people that I've worked with in
an advisory role on YouTube channels and
shows and stuff like that
and we get into all of this detailed
stuff about upload strategy and metadata
and all this stuff and they don't do the
most basic thing which is you've got to
commit to a certain amount of content
and continue uploading it even if
nothing happens for a while we have
almost eight hundred and thirty thousand
subscribers now but after our first year
we only had a few thousand but you have
to keep going that is always step one
unknown prodigy says twitch YouTube and
patreon all three well thank you I very
much appreciate that let me get caught
up on thank-yous here before things get
very very ugly a John Baxter is new
member number four today at John join
pakman.com term 3 is new member number 5
today Steve Turner hey Steve is new
member number 6 at join pakman.com
Martin holid is new member number 7
today
Teddy Pappas is new member number 8
today Thank You Dante
de Savoie de Savoie is new member number
9 Cindy Styne kee has made a pledge on
patreon but I say count it we're
counting at all today dee Ann Wilson is
new
member number 11 I also want to say
thanks to sherry root or root as some
people say I say root is new member
number 12
Laurie Jacques is new member number 13
and Chris Foley hey Chris is new member
number 14 I don't know if that's the
Chris Foley that went to UMass with me
or if it's just a random person named
Chris Foley but in any way I'm
predisposed to like you my friend I
really appreciate the support okay if
you're just joining us we are now seven
minutes past the rescheduled time for
today's press briefing originally
scheduled for five then it got to 5:30
now it's 537 and we are standing by the
room essentially as full as it should be
getting so hopefully we get underway
soon if you are watching on a YouTube
remember to hit the like and subscribe
buttons both are completely free ways to
support the streams other people who are
sending me messages Catherine Walsh has
signed up on YouTube Nemo's or Nemo's
says global cooperation required to
eliminate the virus absolutely
absolutely
Maddie I speedy says David original
pizzeria Regina or Sant rpoS I've never
been to either
I've never been to either I know that
that's it's it's vile but I've never
been to either Christopher Scott sends a
super chat Sarah Holly says on Twitter
Inslee sent Mike Pence a letter
regarding testing I did see that Johnny
Minogue says what did Johnny say did you
and Matt oh used to go bar hopping back
in your Northampton days no I've only
bumped into Rachel Maddow twice in
Northampton is this not Bret Baier now
it doesn't really look like Bret Baier
who it can somebody tell me for sure
whether this is bro it is that it is
Bret bear his behavior is extremely
erratic extremely erratic during this
pre press briefing period I don't know
what is up with him but behaving very
oddly
that suit is tight right tight tight
suit okay
incredible TV sends a message with peace
and love David peace and love rat
cracker says this is Alex Jones Hugh
Jass and Stephen Kenneth destiny bunnell
you don't answer questions and deflect
by saying I didn't see it a real shame
dude all you do is come here and try to
get me to comment on things that mostly
aren't true obviously I'm not going to
talk about it new study out showed
higher mortality rate wid
hydroxychloroquine I do have that here I
had it pulled up for you more deaths no
benefit from malaria drug in Virginia
virus study again all of these are
relatively small studies they're not
often blinded or they don't always have
the right controls this one's of 368
male veterans but you might not have
noticed that Donald Trump hasn't said a
word about hydroxychloroquine he pauses
between the two words he hasn't talked
about it for a week and because it's not
only not working it seems to actually be
hurting some people and remember I have
I would be thrilled if
hydroxychloroquine worked but I told you
about hydroxychloroquine along with
about five or six other possible
treatments weeks before Trump ever
mentioned it I'm not attached at any
emotional way to it Trump went crazy
praising it like a miracle cure and it
appears to be a bad thing
for a lot of coronavirus customers as
they are by default called I want to say
thanks to Heather Golub whose new member
number 15 today Albert needs wacky oh
boy needs FK needs a key I hope that's
correct you are new member number 16
today at joined pakman.com Kathy Mata is
new member number 17 and Tony evitt is
new member number 18
lastly Theresa copping is new member
number 19 today at join pakman.com thank
you so much for the support I so
appreciate it very very much so other
super chats coming in our aquatic says
Maryland governor called out the maps
yesterday as only labs with no tests
available
have capacity but zero tests we need a
pointed nasty question yeah yesterday
this is what I'm talking about when I
tell you that they're lying about
testing first of all Trump said that
testing is doubling each week it's not
look at the numbers from the past seven
days and then look at the numbers from
the previous seven days and the seven
days before that you see that testing is
not doubling every week number two
yesterday there was a direct question
asked what number of tests do we need
and are there enough and dr. Burks
pointed to a map of the testing labs
that doesn't tell us what we need to
know we're talking about how many tests
can actually be done not the number of
labs it's it's absolutely whacked and
they continue to spread disinformation
about that let me say thanks to melody
Haines who has made a pledge on patreon
and we're counting everything today
towards our goal of 25 also Darryl Moss
is new member number 21 today thank you
so much
Christopher Scott sends a super chat
richard sambal and toby allen ii have
subscribed on youtube you love says
david can you pop a squat real quick for
the boys maybe a little bit later we'll
see we'll see if that happens and stand
by for post press conference and and we
can we can discuss that h a phillips has
signed up at the SOI boy level how do
people get the idea that this is work
that that's a comment worthy of spending
money on but hey we'll take it you know
it's Christopher Scott says what's gonna
happen to this here economy mang and
what happened to the hair today oh if
you're just joining me I did shower
before the stream today so it's it's
this is what we call the hair being
under control it's also getting so long
that it's actually kind of falling under
its own weight so we may we may have
turned that we may have peaked and now
we're going back the other way because
it is uh it's getting heavier and under
its own weight it's remaining under
control okay we should be minutes from
the start of this fiasco
anticipating at least two tantrums from
Donald Trump
anticipating some nasty questions and
hoping for some actual explanations
about when we can expect testing to
increase if you're joining me on YouTube
remember to hit the like button and the
subscribe button both buttons are free
much like the banhammer which we just
deploy freely like and subscribe are
also completely free and I encourage you
to use them liberally Brandon humble
says have you heard about the new
stimulus bill that passed where'd that
go and will improve anything I have not
looked at the details of it yet so I'll
have coverage of that tomorrow
Brandon Korey Keane says sorry if you
already discussed this did you see that
video of the man say everyone's been
vaccinated already in the press room
what's up with that I did see it I don't
know what to make of it I I genuinely
have no idea Danny Thompson says have we
seen Alex azar recently tried googling
but nothing recent comes up probably
bound and gagged and locked in a West
Wing closet we have not seen Alex azar
recently and you're right to point it
out Paul Newman says David you are my
silver lining in times like this thank
you so much for being you I will stop
watching Trump's BS briefings today it's
too depressing I understand I understand
Shannon Turnbow has subscribed Charlie
says lol at Brett BAE are really getting
to you today yeah I don't know why his
presence there is really agitating me
it's very weird he's pissing me off
mark Coleman has signed up Daniel Rivera
says thoughts on oil prices going
negative yeah we actually have an
interview publishing at 3 p.m. tomorrow
where we discussed that and I will save
I will allow the experts to comment
tomorrow because they know more than I
do but we've got a great interview about
that coming up let me say thanks to
Zooey Ferguson Zooey is new member
number 22 today at join pakman.com Zooey
thank you I recognize your name I think
you've sent super chats and maybe you're
even a patreon a pleasure as well I
appreciate it Frank mink says Steve
Miller is a
wannabe Joseph Gibble's yeah in a sense
he is Jewish a Stephen Miller but that's
just a minor detail
Kristen Miller says thank you nasty
question says will there be any nasty
questions regarding the Senate
intelligence committees findings I hope
so
they found that Russia interfered to
help Trump in 2016 big surprise Wow
shocker right a Mary Warner says David
do you think we'll ever see Trump be
held accountable
probably not also Iowa hasn't even
peaked yet and governor is talking about
reopening dangerous so Steven minuchin
is here likely because they are going to
talk about all the great stimulus and
not talk about deaths we saw dr. Burks
enter we also this is I believe this is
dr. Hahn is this the FDA guy I think
that's who that is I'm not seeing doctor
foul Qi once again no doctor foul Qi
once again um
Gregory Waldron says by yourself whoa
whoa is that where'd he go Gregory
Waldron buy yourself a new Pantera mask
on me James J says just subscribed on
YouTube thanks for the streams yes take
this advice from James hit that
subscribe button here is Trump coming in
we are going to switch over to the
c-span feed because I find the audio to
be more appropriate on it oh there's an
ad on c-span and they also show video of
the reporters asking questions so we've
agreed that this is this is the feed
that we prefer we will be delayed by
about 15 seconds but I think we will all
survive
thank you very much everyone for a very
big day today I want to start by saying
that our love and prayers of every
American continue to be with our fellow
citizens who have lost a cherished
friend or a family member to the virus
amidst our grief we're making tremendous
strides against this invisible enemy
thanks to our aggressive campaign
against the virus and the extraordinary
talent of our medical professionals
looking orange and we're television rate
remains roughly half of that of many
other countries and one of the lowest of
any country in the world and that's due
to a lot of a lot of things but our
medical professionals have been
incredible since we announced our
guidelines on opening up America as we
call it I see opening up America and we
add the word a gun I think we can add
the word probably again did he say God
but that's what it is we're opening up
America again 20 states representing 40
percent of the US population have
announced that they are making plans and
preparations to safely restart their
economies in the very near future so
that's 20 states it's about 40 percent
of our country they're moving along
pretty quickly three of those today as
you know and they're gonna be doing it
safely they are going to be doing it
with tremendous passion there's they
want to get back to work the country
wants to get back to work it's your time
ago the Senate passed the Paycheck
protection program and our health care
Enhancement Act comes a business with
additional funding for the Paycheck
protection program hospitals and testing
a lot of money for all of them
especially for our workers and our small
businesses my administration has worked
aggressively with Congress to negotiate
this critical 482 billion dollar funding
package we reached a deal that includes
382 billion dollars and
crucial small-business support to keep
workers on the payroll 75 billion
dollars to aid hospitals which really
need the aid and very badly very proud
of that and 25 billion dollars to
support coronavirus testing efforts I
urge the house to pass the bill and
they're going to be voting on it I
imagine very very soon I think while
we're here and so he's a very busy man
as you know secretary minuchin he's
going to be running back so I thought
would do we'll talk about that now and
we'll take a couple of questions on that
and then he can go and start phase four
as the ink is drying probably they'll be
voting tomorrow how fun right this is so
fun I'm glad Trump's having fun shortly
and I think we have tremendous support
so Steve please come up say a few words
Dave yeah Thank You mr. president and
thank you for all your work with us to
get this passed I'd especially like to
thank Mitch McConnell and Chuck Schumer
and the entire Senate for passing this
I'd also like to thank Kevin McCarthy
and Nancy Pelosi who have been working
with us around the clock as well and our
chief of staff Mark meadows who is also
very instrumental in this let me just
comment we've had tremendous support for
the PPP this gives us another three
hundred and ten billion dollars for the
PPP we look forward to the house passing
this tomorrow in being up and running
quickly after that this also gives us 50
billion dollars for disaster loans idle
loans that will allow the SBA to make
300 billion dollars of disaster loans
all for small businesses also allows us
as the president said more money to
hospitals and unprecedented amount of
money for testing and and again I think
we understand hospitals not only the
hospitals that have been impacted by
coronavirus but more importantly many
hospitals that have been shut down and
making sure that the doctors and nurses
get money now let me make just one more
comment on the program we have over a
million
that have received this with less than
10 workers so there is very broad
participation and in really small
business I will comment there have been
some big businesses that have taken
these loans I was pleased to see the
Shake Shack returned to the money we
will be putting out some fa Q's there is
a certification that people are making
and I ask people just make sure the
intent of this was for business that
needed the money we'll put out an FAQ
but again the intent of this money was
not for big public companies that have
access to capital so mr. secretary are
you gonna request that those other
companies obviously Shake Shack was not
alone in being a big company that
they've got money in this replay you're
gonna ask them I'm gonna return that
money yep Harvard's gonna pay back the
money and they shouldn't be taking about
properties collect you you have a number
of I'm not gonna mention any other names
but when I saw Harvard they have a one
of the largest endowments anywhere in
the country maybe the world I guess I
just want to clarify because certain
people on the PPP may have not been
clear and understanding the
certification so we will give people the
benefit of the doubt we're gonna write
an FAQ out explain the certification if
you pay back the loan right away you
won't have liability to the SBA and to
Treasury but there are severe
consequences
for people who don't test properly this
certification and again we want to make
sure this money is available to small
businesses that need it people who have
invested their entire life savings
we appreciate what's going on and in
their hiring people back how are you to
ensure that those small businesses those
small restaurants cafes bars who did not
get the money last time around
this time well as I said you know there
are a million a million of these
companies that did get it that are very
small working with the banks were
extremely pleased that the small banks
did great 20% of the loans were made by
banks of a billion unless 60% by by 20
billion in less and the the big banks
also we want everybody to participate
there's no a lot of money back in the
program and we look forward to all these
small businesses getting access to funds
brett is great to see you here Thank You
secretary and you know estimate how long
this is going to take that other pot of
money obviously went quickly Jews assume
this is going to go quickly as well well
let me just say I mean you know kind of
we're pleased with the success of this
program and how quickly this got up
operationally we've we've put out more
money in these SBA loans than in the
last 10 years of SBA so I want to thank
all the banks that have worked really
hard we knew that when we passed this
originally if there was full take out we
wouldn't have enough money that's why
we've worked with Congress for more
money and this is gonna you know we've
already impacted about 30 million
workers they'll be they'll be a lot more
so we look forward to this having a big
impact on the economy yesterday the
president said look into the issue of
felons those conditions I'm not getting
access to some of these programs we
worked with the White House on this
there were actually much more onerous
restrictions in the SBA program there
were people who had misdemeanors that
that weren't allowed to access the
program it was much longer than five
years and you know we very much because
of the criminal reform legislation that
was passed and the work that's been done
in the White House by Jared and others
we specifically designed the program in
the five years was significantly shorter
than what had been done before so we had
already taken that into account right
now we're not going to do that but I
want to just emphasize we did take this
into account there were a lot of people
that wouldn't have access previously and
we change those regulations
the president talked about a phase for I
know we all understand the circumstances
and why businesses need this but how
many more phases can we afford to have
or can businesses expect to have a ducey
up phase five what's your thinking on
this well first of all I very much
appreciate the president's support for
phase four he put out a tweet as the
president said we would look forward to
phase four would be
infrastructure the president's been
talking about infrastructure since the
campaign roads bridges broad bands
especially broadband now to rural
America is is very important we've
talked about incentives for restaurants
sports entertainment because these
businesses have been impacted the
president has talked multiple times
about a payroll tax cut and we've also
we're talking about in the case of
states the states we've heard from the
governor's and the fiscal issues of the
states I don't know I don't know you
must likely be what we need I think
based upon what we're seeing and the
reopening of the economy and the amount
of money we're putting in and working
with the Federal Reserve on 13-3 I think
you're gonna see a lot of liquidity and
we look forward to business rebounding
especially later this summer just real
quick to follow up and the PPP program
is this the last tranche of money you
think you're gonna need for small
businesses we would expect this is the
last tranche but obviously we can always
reconsider that but this is a lot of
money going out again let me just be
clear you know it's it's another 310
billion here and another 300 billion of
loans that's over six hundred billion
dollars putting into small businesses
which are the backbone of the economy
50% of the private payroll for us to
comment what the cost is we'll work with
Congress on that and we'll consider it
that's gonna be taxpayer dollars that
are going out the door you fellas come
to a different way of thinking about the
need for oversight independent oversight
on behalf of the taxpayer we have
independent oversight we supported in in
the last legislation let me be very
clear we have a new inspector general
the president has already picked someone
for that position we look forward to the
person being confirmed we have an
oversight committee of Congress that
many of them have already been appointed
and let me just say we put up last week
for full transparency we have no
obligation to do this we put up you can
go to Treasury gov full transparency on
the money that had been sent out on the
PPP across states showing all the big
lenders how it was distributed no one
lender did more than 4% showed the
businesses so again the president I very
much believe in full transparency we're
spending a lot of money and we want to
make sure that it's done effectively and
fairly thank you you started by thanking
the leaders in the House and the Senate
can you tell us more about how easy or
hard it was to deal with both sides well
we've been working around the clock
I think there's been very good
bipartisan support to get this done the
the Congress is coming together
understanding the importance of this and
we've been working round the clock for
days so this is important legislation it
was a lot we spoke to a lot of people
mark Meadows has been fantastic as I
said it's great to have him here in the
White House I couldn't have done this
without him working on this with me and
the president and vice president have
been available to us around the clock so
this was a big team effort press
absolutely we couldn't have done this
today without unanimous consent and the
Democrats being on board and we look
forward to this being passed on a
bipartisan basis tomorrow this is a real
example of the country coming together
differently for this virus
best understanding of what Mitch
McConnell wants for the restaurant again
I think we're not we're not at the point
of designing that like every other bill
we will work with senators on on both
sides on a bipartisan basis I can tell
you there's a lot of support
particularly for things like broadband
and especially what's going on today but
the president has talked about you know
I was on the campaign with the president
we've been talking about bridges and
tunnels and rebuilding this country for
years so the president wants to make a
big investment in this this Mitch
McConnell billion dollars portion of
cares reserved for companies credit
being critical for national security and
also will all companies fit into that at
all per the president's food so we're in
the process of putting out guidance that
that part was really designed for
national security companies that are
either major suppliers to the Department
of Defense were companies that have top
secret clearance so the this that
national security provision was was very
clear when we did that the president has
asked me to work with the Secretary of
Energy obviously the energy business is
very important to us this has national
security issues but different and we
look forward to both looking at what
existing capabilities we have and that
will be something we may need to go back
to Congress planning to both bail out
oil companies and finagle things to get
the price of oil up absolutely different
situation I mean what you have with the
airlines is you know we had a very very
good airline industry because of the
virus they basically shut down we have a
situation now with the the oil business
partially because of the virus okay for
Less demand but partially also because
of too much supply but you know the
president is determined we want to
maintain our energy independence and the
president has asked me to look at all of
our options and what we're doing that
obviously it's a pretty extraordinary
situation where you saw the front month
of oil futures trade negative
the forth stimulus bill and aid to state
and local governments
any thoughts on whether that money
should be proportionate to have the rate
of infection in states with it'd be
interesting but way too early to
consider that whatever we do we'll do on
a bipartisan basis
the president has listened to the
governor's I've had the opportunity on
multiple video conference calls with the
President and the Vice President we're
reaching out to a lot of people there's
a lot of states that have been impacted
but way too early to figure out that
level of design a large company applies
for one of these loans and they
manipulates their works of system or
work some loopholes to get it what are
some the consequences to you know a
large company tries to give of these PPP
loans what can you do well you used the
word manipulate I'm going to give people
the benefit of the doubt again we're
going to put up very clear guidance so
that people understand what the
certification is what it means if you're
a big company again there is a provision
for you know where there are multiple
affiliates that people can access this
but the intent was not for companies
that have access to plenty of liquidity
and other sources and and again if to
the extent these companies didn't
understand this and they repay the loans
that will be okay and if not they'll be
potentially other consequences can you
talk about what those consequences again
you can look at the certifications
they're they're quite significant
how many jobs have been saved with all
the money that's going out in the PPP so
far well I can't tell you the PPP so far
is over 30 million jobs and and again
that doesn't account for other money
that we've sent out and again we're very
pleased the direct deposits have gone
out we've started sending out the checks
we're also going to be supplementing our
capability and sending prepaid debit
cards so we can get money out quickly to
people so everything that the president
has had us working on is providing
significant stability in the economy
while we're dealing with this difficult
time when for medical reasons we closed
down major parts of the economy so the
noble fight against the invisible enemy
is inflicted a steep toll on the market
workforce as we all know millions of
Americans sacrificed their jobs in order
to battle the virus and save the lives
of our fellow citizens we have a solemn
duty to ensure these unemployed
Americans regain their jobs and their
livelihoods therefore in order to
protect American workers I will be
issuing a temporary suspension of
immigration into the United States you
heard about that last night by parsing
immigration will help put unemployed
Americans first in line for jobs as
America reopens so important it would be
wrong and unjust for Americans laid off
by the virus to be replaced with new
immigrant labor flown in from abroad we
must first take care of the American
worker take care of the American worker
this pause will be in effect for 60 days
after which the need for any extension
or modification will be evaluated by
myself and a group of people based on
economic conditions at the terminus that
things are so great that 20 states are
opening but for two months he needs to
stop all immigration because things are
so uniquely bad hmm doesn't make sense
huh all rights big factor will not apply
to those entering on a temporary
as we move forward we'll examine what
additional immigration related measures
should be put in place to protect US
workers we want to protect our US
workers and I think as we move forward
we will become more and more protective
of them this pause our new immigration
will also help to conserve vital medical
resources for American citizens a short
break from new immigration depending on
the time we're talking about will
protect the solvency of our health care
system and provide relief to jobless
Americans today vice president pence
visited the hard-working men and women
of General Electric health care in
Madison Wisconsin working three shifts a
day to quadruple their production of
ventilators we're way ahead of schedule
on ventilators as you know that's why
it's never brought up by the media
they're like you know doing so well ge
is also working with Ford to make 50,000
ventilators in the next 100 days more
than our entire country typically
produces in a very long period of time
doing that in a matter of a few weeks
and a few days earlier today I had a
very productive meeting with Governor
Cuomo as you probably saw to discuss his
statewide testing strategy and how we
can work together to help expand it with
the goal of doubling testing in the next
few weeks and New York State will be
continuing to control the testing of
their citizens and will also manage
their state and local laboratories they
have a lot of great laboratories there
any tests that more than anybody would
ever have known frankly the federal
government will work along with the
state on the national manufacturers and
distributors if the high right together
we'll all work together to help them
secure additional tests and we hope that
this model will work with the other
states as well I think it will for the
most part New York has a lot of very
exceptional laboratories but most of the
states dudes you saw the chart yesterday
most of the states
this is the thing they talk about the
number of labs the labs may be
processing zero tests New York and I can
say very honestly with New York State in
New York City they've been terrific to
work with the New York metropolitan area
has been the epicenter of the outbreak
here in America and the federal
government has spared no expense or
resource to get New Yorkers the care
they need and the care they deserve
we've sent over 5 million masks we had
five million masks and now that number
as of about two days from now will be
more than doubled
thousands of ventilators in fact so many
ventilators that the governor is going
to be sending up some to to
Massachusetts and a couple of other
locations we have a great deal of
ventilators which people thought would
be impossible about a month ago
thousands of hospital beds and the USNS
comfort was sent as you know to New York
and it was originally for more of a
normal medical purpose and we changed it
over so that it could take care of
people that had the unfortunate
circumstance of going through the
problem that we that we know so well
unfortunately that we know so well I
said from the beginning that no American
who needs a ventilator would be denied a
ventilator and we have kept that promise
all over the United States think of that
the good guys are desperate for
ventilators they have many deaths
because they don't have a ventilator and
I've asked Andrew if we could bring the
comfort back to its base in Virginia so
that we can have it for other locations
and he said we would be able to do that
Javits Center has been a great help to
them but we'll be bringing the ship back
at the earliest time and we'll get it
ready for its next mission which will
I'm sure would be a very important one
also but it was it was an honor they
they reconverted it after it got there
into
handling an event that they were not
expecting to be handling the FDA is now
authorized around 50 diagnostic tests
including as of late last night the
first taste test that a patient can take
home you can take it on haunt let's
think this is what matters
it's a highly accurate LabCorp intends
to make the Home Collection kits
available to consumers in most states
with a doctor's order in the coming
weeks we also afford different antibody
tests already authorized tests will help
identify individuals who can donate
convalescent plasma plasma thus
providing potentially life-saving
antibodies to American patients moptop
dr. Han will be providing you with an
update on these developments in a few
moments he's done a great job at the FDA
we continue to gain ground in the war
against the unseen enemy and I see light
at the end of the tunnel I actually see
a lot of light at the end of the tunnel
and we're starting the process we're
starting a very very powerful important
process you see that people are getting
very anxious they want to get going they
want to get back to their jobs they want
to make money they want to take care of
their families
so the light is getting brighter and
brighter every day and with that if I
could I'll ask dr. Burks to come up and
then dr. Hahn thank you very much
prepare yourself
Thank You mr. president so I'm looking
at all of the information across the
United States we do see improvement
across all the large metros I know you
know that we've been talking about the
New York metro area New York City Rhode
Island Connecticut Long Island and
really we do start to see improvement
there and we see improvement even now in
in Rhode Island and Connecticut the
Detroit Metro is doing quite well with
significant declines now New Orleans is
nearly backed to their baseline of where
they started for new infections we also
are seeing improvements in Chicago and
Boston and that has been a great concern
for us over the last several weeks if
they appear now to be flattening both
also Philadelphia and Houston Atlanta
Nashville Baltimore Indianapolis and st.
Louis also appear to be flattening the
DC metro area we don't see a decline yet
so I'm hopefully all of you is still
social distancing and doing everything
that you can I wanted to remind
everybody of two points when we brought
up and the president put out the
guidelines for opening up America again
it was very clear to use data and to
really work together to mitigate against
any resurgence and also critically to
protect the vulnerable and what we're
seeing across rural America and some of
the smaller pop population states is
we're still seeing outbreaks in
long-term care facilities and we asked
everyone in phase 1 to make sure that
they continued their social distancing
and public to ensure that the vulnerable
with comorbidities and other conditions
and among the elderly where we're
staying at home and making sure we're
still providing service to them but as
individual Americans as we begin to open
up we also made it very clear that
individual Americans need to continue
all of their hygiene pieces ensuring
social distancing washing hands
not touching their face and making sure
that they're not bringing the virus home
to vulnerable individuals within the
household and remember those were to
continue through all three phases and so
really want to call people's attention
and go onto the guidelines we are
continuing to see outbreaks in nursing
homes and in confined spaces and I think
as Americans we want to stop that and we
have the ability to do that by really
paying attention to the guidelines that
were to be in all three phases and so
calling on the states again to note that
an informed community and knowledgeable
community as a protected community so
make sure all of your states have your
cases visible to the communities so they
can make decisions and understand where
the virus is in their community and
understand how to tackle it with their
state and local governments this will be
absolutely critical and there's
surveillance that we called for to find
asymptomatic before people get sick with
as an early warning signal it's supposed
to be in the federal clinics in our
inner city more vulnerable areas among
indigenous populations and of course in
our long-term care facilities and
prisons we really want to support state
and local governments to move forward on
these critical monitoring to protect
individuals that may be in the most
critically vulnerable States we will
continue to see mortality and deaths
among our American citizens particularly
in the cities as they begin to move past
peak because deaths will lag and so we
really need to continue to unite and
really really really support our health
care providers who are still on the
front lines they have been on the front
lines now for weeks and weeks and weeks
and so no matter what city they have
been in they have not seen the relief
that we've been able to talk about it
the at light at the end of the tunnel
because of the delay in hospitalizations
and deaths so to our health care
providers to our respiratory therapists
and to everyone in the labs thank you
for the work that you're doing to
protect Americans and give us one of the
lowest mortality rates in the
your world thank you any word on when
we're gonna do more tests anybody Thank
You mr. president and I just want to
echo what dr. Burke said just a few few
short months ago I was one of those
doctors on the frontlines and I know how
terrific they're working and how well
they're doing for the American people
and I shout out to them for just the
wonderful work that they that they do
every day so President Trump asked the
FDA to remove all unnecessary barriers
that were in place to help with the
development of both diagnostics and
therapeutics and we have done that I'm
here to give you an update on FDA's
efforts around serologic tests which as
you know are antibody tests which detect
in the blood the natural immunity that
someone might develop in response to
infection in the high schoo vat19 oh
yeah these aren't diagnostic tests but
these are tests that actually detect the
antibody so an indication that one has
had the infection and has responded and
I think it's important for everyone to
understand that the timing of the
response of the antibody to the
infection isn't completely known but we
know that it takes some time to actually
develop that and there's two types of
antibody responses that can be detected
and the antibody tests are just one
piece of the larger response that you've
heard in the America returning to work a
plan that the president has with Task
Force has developed and this pandemic is
truly unprecedented in nature and you'll
see reports around the world of
different antibody tests that have been
used and I think that's a reflection of
the fact that we're just learning done
and beginning to understand what that
response looks like and many of these
tests have different characteristics
that allow to detect at different points
in the infection I do want to address
one issue that we are laser focused on
at FDA and that is in an effort to
provide laboratories and health care
providers the early access to tests we
issued a policy earlier in March that
allowed test developers the opportunity
to quickly get their tests to market and
address the needs of the nation as posed
by the epidemic in March we provided
this regulatory flexibility to
manufacturers and here's what we
required of them the manufacturers had
to validate their tests we call it self
validation similar to what
many test developers in the world have
done they had to notify FDA that they
had performed that validation and then
they had to label their products
appropriately in the package insert with
information about the validation as well
as the fact that it's not a diagnostic
test that it's an antibody test in the
bottom line here is that FDA still
expects manufacturers and test
developers to validate their antibody
tests even under this revised policy now
we've done a couple of things to
actually help end users to help
laboratories providers etc States in
terms of their use of these antibody
tests
one is that we're working with CDC and
NCI to actually validate some of the
more than ninety manufacturers who have
notified us that they brought their test
to market to do an independent
validation and that process is going we
expect to hear more information this
week about that and we will provide that
information in a transparent manner we
also want to go after anyone who is
office saying that that test has been
authorized or has or has been approved
by the FDA but actually hasn't and we've
authorized for applications for antibody
tests and a hundred and forty test
developers are pursuing applications for
us as we speak so it's not okay for
someone to say that a Testament authors
are approved by FDA when it hasn't
they're never pursuing them both by in
direct contact with the manufacturers
but also at the border and so we have
increased these interdiction efforts and
we will continue to outreach and do and
do that with the manufacturers to make
sure that we provide the most up-to-date
information to the N use of these
products and we will continue to do make
all of our efforts both in the
Diagnostics and the therapeutics to help
America open up again
Thank You mr. president
[Music]
you're speaking of 140 different
developers more than 90 manufacturers
how many of these tests actually work so
as I mentioned the 90 that I've come
forward and said they're marketing the
u.s. they are required by us to have
self validation it's not required to
label that appropriately in their
package insert I also said that what
we're doing is we're working with folks
around the country but here at home in
the US government with the NCI and CDC
to validate some of those tests that
have come forward to us so we're
actually doing sittin tip independent
evaluate ballot so far so we don't have
those results yet I expect to have more
results this week but we'll be
transparent about those results because
you think it's very important and your
question is superb in that if someone
wants to use a test that's come to
market really it's important to read the
information that's in the package insert
but often in some of those cases it's
also important for the independent labs
to do the validation also and you may
have seen reports in the press of labs
around the country that have done that
we've actually reached out to the many
academics and we will be including that
information in the information that we
generate as well to provide to the
American people there was a study out of
the VA today on hydroxychloroquine that
found the higher mortality rate compared
to those who got standard of care I know
this isn't a large-scale clinical trial
but since the drug is out there and
people are using it can you give some
takeaways from that study how big did
that figure thinking at all so this
study is a small retrospective study at
the VA and and similar to the data we
talked about before with the French
study this is something that a doctor
would need to consider as part of the
decision in writing prescription for
eyedrops and chloroquine and as I've
mentioned from this podium in and other
venues before with what FDA is gonna
require is data from clinical trials
randomized clinical trials
hydroxychloroquine placebo to actually
make a definitive decision around safety
and efficacy but the preliminary data
are helpful to providers and doctors I
want to ask them to incorporate the data
as we have it come forward and it's not
definitive data it doesn't help us make
a decision from a regulatory point of
view but doctors should incorporate that
in the decision-making they
make on a one-on-one basis just the
timeline on the clinical trials and when
we will be getting a readout of that
data yeah so the good news is we have
over 30 clinical trials now the settings
are very different they're in the
outpatient setting they're in the
inpatient setting and also I think very
importantly in what we call the post
exposure prophylaxis meaning if you're a
healthcare work or a frontline provider
and you've been exposed to the virus
take the drug for a period of time to
see if you can prevent the development
of illness related to the virus
so all those trials are in progress and
will probably be early summer before we
get a readout in addition to the tests
that we already have question really had
a hydroxy my friend people than anybody
anywhere in the world by far by very far
I wonder if you're concerned this this
VA study showed that actually more
people died they use the drug that
didn't and I'm wondering if the Governor
Cuomo brought you back any results no
I'm discuss it and I don't know of the
report obviously there have been some
very good reports and I'm glad perhaps
this one's not a good report but we'll
be looking at it we'll have a comment on
this panel of experts at the NIH is
actually now recommending against the
use of hydroxychloroquine in combination
with z-pak which is something you okay
always willing to take a look Brett
other subject you were standing at the
exact War when do you plan to do that
the executive order will be it's being
written now as we speak probably
tomorrow sometimes unclear that it would
have exemptions in there will have
certain exemptions cuz you're gonna need
certain exemptions but we'll be
notifying you tomorrow we'll sign it
most likely tomorrow being drawn now and
tonight and it's something we have to
have in this country we have to have it
the people who say doesn't track with
opening up the country yet to shut down
immigration across the board for
companies that and and the pipeline
that's already in place what do you say
to them well I think it really does I
think it's very strong obviously and
it's kind of wide as opposed to
specifically like China or some
assignments that I've shut down we're
gonna see it you'll see a very accurate
concussion tomorrow after it's completed
but they're right that lesson for me uh
North Korea what do you what can you
tell us about the status Kim Jong well
these are reports that came out and we
don't know we don't know I've had a very
good relationship with them I wouldn't
you know I can only say this I wish him
well because if he is in the kind of
condition that the reports say that the
news is saying that would be a that's a
very serious condition as you know but I
wish him well then we've had a good
relationship I've said it and I've said
it many times if somebody else were in
this position we would have been right
now at war with North Korea I'm not at
war and we're nowhere close to war with
North Korea so I just have to say to Kim
jong-un I wish him very you know good
luck good luck I mean they came out with
very very serious medical reports
nobody's confirmed that it's was seeing
then that came out so when CNN comes out
with the report
I don't place too much credence in it
convince you of a need for expanded
testing or con testing and we have an
agreement that we have an understanding
on testing they have labs tremendous
labs as you know in New York especially
out in the Manhattan area but all over
the site in great great medical schools
and federal labs so we we have a very
good understanding we're gonna do very
significant testing you know not
everybody wants to do such significant
testing
well testing medically is good in some
cases and in some cases it's not you
have governors that don't want to go all
out on the testing because they think
they can do it in a different manner and
do it better but we had a very good
meeting today the governor and I had a
very good man there mental aid that can
be used to help governor's who want to
expand testing because we keep here yet
five billion dollars and that's a
tremendous amount of money that's a much
more more money than in my opinion that
we'll need and again already we're
testing more by far than any country I
think I read yesterday that we've done
more than everybody else every other
country combined and I think our people
should be getting a lot of credit for
this updated even if you remove tiny
countries like San Marino we are still
only 28th and testing per capita it's
perfect I've spent on the executive
order representing you men to need their
own visa exemptions we're reporting
right now that they only applies to
employment
in green three hearts for employment -
not for those four we're gonna be
reporting on that later on it might be
tonight or tomorrow we'll give you an
exact report you can set people who may
be worried about difficulty building a
family
no I think it's been covered pretty
accurately in this case I think most
people know what it is and some people
will be able to get in we have to do
that obviously even from a humane
standpoint but there'll be there'll be
some people coming in but it's a it's a
strong order a big big circle as you
know please immigrants who are already
in the country are they a greater risk
of deportation based on this order I
don't think I don't think so they're not
supposed to be here you're saying
they're here illegally is that what you
say well for example if an immigrant is
here for a court order right then you
have to go to court so then the judge
would make a determination as to whether
or not they're going to be staying but
if they have a court order they won't
have to leave until they go through that
process so we'll see what happens but
with the court and there are some with
court orders that means they have a
trial coming up please it's so obviously
on the immigration executive order
you've raised concern for a long time
even in good economic times about
immigrants taking Americans jobs so
under what conditions would you consider
lifting this halt on immigration yeah
sort of an opportunity to address what
you've seen as a problem for a lot
time well I think look right now
obviously there's never been where the
greatest economy in the world and then
one day we had to shut it down they said
you have to shut it down we did the
right thing because I think we would
have had a million or maybe even two
million it may be more than that death
so we did the right thing but certainly
this would pertain I mean when you look
at it right now the last thing we want
to do is take American workers jobs it's
one thing when we were essentially they
used to call it full employment and it's
another thing right now right now we
have people that have lost their jobs
and we hope they're going to come back
and come back fast and that we can have
an even heated discussion right now we
have to have jobs for Americans like if
unemployment gets to 4% or 5% I love to
see I mean I hope we're in that position
to have that debate right now we're not
in that position right now we'd closed
down a the largest economy the greatest
economy in the history of the world it's
the most successful economy when you
look at the stock market we're breaking
records
virtually every week sometimes every day
and stock markets still not doing badly
considering what this country has been
through which way tells you how strong
it was in the first place
but no I hope we're gonna be able to
have that discussion I hope we're in a
position that's like a good discussion
to have but that'll be a little bit
later Brett for dr. Burks about the CDC
director said in there
that perhaps this second wave of the
coronavirus in the fall could be worse
because it is timed with the seasonal
flu just wondering if you can talk about
that in context of as you're opening up
the country and these guidelines that
you've laid out yeah so we were very
clear in the guidelines that we believe
we can monitor again monitor communities
at the community level by using the
influenza like illness and the cinder
ohmic respiratory and gastrointestinal
components of this of this particular
virus obviously when we have flu we're
going to and we're working on an
algorithm that you test for flu and then
you test for covet and making sure that
we are building the testing capacity to
be able to do that because I think it's
very important that you're going to be
able I on that wave q be worse they come
in with early flu and early kovat can
look very close to get identical so we
need to have testing in place to be able
to separate and ensure those patients or
see the best treatment we're also hoping
by that time that we have additional
treatment options for people with toph
at 19 so that there will be additional
treatment available in the fall that
don't come back together the president
has made it clear that we have the
emergency which we have been working on
the opening up guidelines and just like
he talks about phase four he has us very
much working on the next 6090 and for
all on with fall and that's why he's not
stopped any of the ventilator orders
it's very important for that we have a
completely refreshed and a comprehensive
stockpile going into the fall and I
think that's why we continue to bring in
those shipments and work on the
ventilators so that those would be
available not only for the United States
but certainly if other other partner
countries have this new level of tragedy
follow up on that tip so you agree this
could come back actually worse in the
fall there will be worse I think this
has been pretty bad when you see what
has happened in New York that was very
bad I believe that will have early
warning signals both from our
surveillance that we've been talking on
about in these on the vulnerable
populations we're going to continue that
surveillance from now all the way
through the fall to be able to give us
that early warning signal I think what
we've learned is how good Americans are
about immediately reverting to all of
those issues that they need to do in
order to ensure that they're protected
and their families mr. president what do
you say there's concerns like Georgia is
is opening up barber shops and bowling
alleys in the light and you saw Lindsey
Graham is saying he's concerned that
Georgia may be going too far too fast it
could affect people in South Carolina
obviously people travel back and forth
between states how do you protect the
people of South Carolina for example
from a potentially bad decision by a
governor in Georgia so he's a very
capable man he knows what he's doing
he's done a very good job as governor
Georgia and and by the way in South
Carolina Governor McMaster also so you
have two very capable people we're going
to find out and in fact I'm scheduled to
speak to the governor of Georgia in a
little while but we'll we'll find it
Graham's concerned what happens in
Georgia I have no concern about what
happens everywhere I mean we've got
those concerns and as far as coming back
if they do come back and they could come
back together with heavy on the flu and
much lighter on because I really believe
we'll be able to put out the fires you
know it's like fires and we've learned a
lot you know we've become very good at
this when you look at what's happening
when you look at the numbers coming down
a lot of states are in really great
shape you're gonna see a lot of openings
but I'll be speaking to the governor of
Georgia in a little while
mr. president the American people need
to be prepared for going back to social
distancing even if things relax over the
summers summer come the fall if the man
comes that includes I could see them and
I'll speak for the doctor and if you'd
like either of you to say but I would
say that you keep away or until this
thing is gone it's gonna be gone at some
point it's gonna be gun gun and I would
say you keep away and you do the social
distancing until such time as you know
it's good we'll know what that time is
your executive order is through the last
for 60 days how will you decide whether
to extend it this is what I look at
we'll see where we are with the economy
basically and I think I'll have a very
easy decision to make I hope I hope that
the economy is gonna be great by that
time but we'll see but right now in
light of the fact that Americans are out
of jobs I can't be have I can't be taken
in for another 60 days replica or I
could roll it for 30 days or I could
roll it for much more than 60 days we
have to take a look at the time but
we'll be looking at 60 days and we'll
see what it is you go why don't you go
and then the immigration order will
continue with that there is reporting
that you may actually sign a second
order to even limit more of those
exceptions that you were just talking
about can you confirm that you've I want
but I won't be doing it tomorrow I'll be
signing the primary order and then we
have a secondary order that if I want to
do that will make that determination we
can do that yeah we can do that at a
little bit different time if we want
that is under consideration of the
our secondary orders yeah please
Thank You mr. president have two
questions one from me and one from a
reporter who couldn't be in the room
because of so my first question is about
your immigration order you campaigned on
reducing legal immigration I remember
your speech in Phoenix and 2016 on
reducing legal immigration legal and
illegal but no I've always said you have
to come into the country legally
so not let them ask the question what I
campaigned on was people just flooding
our border and stopping and by the way
speaking of that we have 170 miles
almost 170 miles of a very powerful
border wall up and it's moving rapidly
very quickly and it's having a
tremendous impact and it's making our
job a lot easier plus Mexico has 27,000
soldiers right now on our southern
border that we share with them and
Mexico has been terrific they've really
helped you also campaigned on reducing
legal immigration and I'm wondering if
some critics are saying that you are
using the virus now in this crisis to
follow through on that promise to reduce
legal in there no no well I want people
that are in this country I want our
citizens to get jobs I don't want them
to have competition we have a very
unusual situation where something came
in that nobody has seen for many many
decades probably 1917 would be the
closest analogy if you look at it when
you look at the contagion the kind of
contagion we're talking about so no I'm
not I'm not doing that at all I want I
want the American worker and the
American our American citizens to be
able to get jobs I don't want them to
compete right now there's a big
difference when we have a full economy
and frankly where some of the companies
we have many companies moving in where
they need actually they need workers
that's a big difference between that and
where all of a sudden a lot of people
lose jobs as you know a lot of farmers
rely on seasonal migrant workers
expected the farmers will not be that's
an important point the farmers will not
be affected
yeah that's very important point I mean
it's a great point actually I've I'm
glad you brought it up know the farmers
will not be affected your they stopped
everybody from coming in and all the
farmers went out of business they were
literally at a business you remember
that bread it was not so long ago but
they it's easy you know it's easier to
stop everything cold than it is to plant
it so that the farmers have the people
that have been working in those farms
for many years and and that's what we're
doing no the farmers will not be
affected by this at all if anything
we're gonna make it easier and we're
doing a process that'll make it better
for those workers to come in to go to
the farm where they've been for a long
time we go for questions for reporters
out of the rivers for The Washington
Times Tom Howell why hasn't the CDC the
federal government's main
disease-fighting agency had a more
public facing role and then the pandemic
if it was holding regular media calls
early on that is not held one since
early to mid March well I can't tell you
that the CDC has been terrific we've
worked with him very closely they were
very much involved even in the border
decision that I made last night and the
directors the directors don't have a job
we have always whether it's Tony or
Deborah or Steve we have always a lot of
people up and certainly had you've seen
the directors been here a lot right he's
been here he's been sitting here has
been speaking a lot
no no CDC is very much involved in
everything we've done the director of
CDC said that protests against Al Mars
are not helpful you've encouraged some
of these protests what are your thoughts
on the CDC director saying people look
it's not a question of helpful or not
people want to get back to work and I
watched some of the protests not in
great detail but I've seen that and
they're separated they're a lot of space
in between I mean they they're watching
believe it or not social they're doing
social distancing if you can believe it
and they are and they're protesting but
they lie they're covering the group's
I've seen have been very much spread out
so much a lot I think that's good look
people they want to get back to work
they got to make a living they have to
take
they're family they don't want to do
this it's a you know unfortunate maybe
one way or the other both are
unfortunate both are unfortunate but you
have a lot of people out there that are
anxious to get back people are actually
more concerned more people are concerned
about the virus spread they don't want
to go out to groups they both their big
groups both of them just what what good
is it for these businesses that would
reopen if the customer we have to build
back our country and I'm gonna make our
country bigger and better and stronger
and we have to get started there's a big
difference though because people have
really been through a lot and they
understand what to do now before nobody
had ever because Trump is spewing
nonsense I'll jump in I'm talking to a
lot of people who are telling me if
restaurants open I'm still only getting
takeout and mostly staying at home if
the barber shop opens I'm not going to
the barber shop right now so there is
certainly a question there's also a
question of if you open one of those
businesses are employees going to then
before going unemployment and what's the
net benefit I mean there's some real
questions in there hey the governors are
going to do because I want the governors
and I've always wanted that you could go
literalism you can call her whatever you
want but the governor's I want them to
do it if they if we see them doing
something we don't like we'll stop it
very quickly but they're doing a good
job they're being careful some of the
governor's frankly they're in a position
where they can do it sooner or they can
do it a little bit later and that's okay
but people really don't want to they
they need money they need help we're
going to lose and we can't break our
country over this we can't do it we have
to get going with that being said some
are gonna go soon and some are not yeah
in the back if I might just I'm just
burnt part mate Hair Salons nail salons
tattooed partners dr. Burks can you
weigh in on this because the people of
Atlanta want to hear from you as well as
much as they want to get from their
governor how do you 6:7 for them safely
have hair salons and nail salons and
tattoo parlors where people wear
everything where is this is enjoyed
anywhere people have to inherently be
close together I think what I've been
trying to communicate over the last
several days is it's really important
that the governors and mayor's
communicate critical information to
their communities and show very clearly
on advocate dr. Burks is nonsense
evidence-based the data that they
utilize to make decisions and the data
that the mayor should use in each of the
communities because it will have to be
on a community by community opening
because there are different communities
and different claims is there any way to
do a nail salon and have social
distancing and not risk spreading I
don't think there is their cases are not
going down that they need to continue to
do everything that we said social
distancing washing your hands wearing a
mask in public so if there's a way that
people can social distance and do those
things then they can do those things I
don't know how but right people are very
creative there you go so I'm not going
to prejudge but we have told people very
clearly in the president guidelines made
it very clear about the expectations of
phase one and remember phase one also
included social distancing and
restaurants social distancing in every
place that was entertainments and
keeping your own individual social
groups to less than ten and we've been
very clear in the guidelines and I think
it's up to the governors and mayor's to
ensure that they're following the best
they can each of those phases to make
sure that both of the public is
completely protected but the governors
and mayor's also need to communicate
very clearly on the data that was used
for decision making and make that
transparent and available to their
communities
there's an example that you just gave
are they doing testing before they go in
we have to find that out that's why I'm
speaking to the governor a little while
nobody asking them those questions
please Thank You mr. president just try
to get a sense of what you have left my
toolbox as it relates to whoa you you
hashed out the deal with hope that bus
you've ordered for purchases into the
SPR I mean what else can be the biggest
thing that the toolbox is to get our
country open that's by far the biggest
thing there is if we can open pretty
well and I think we're going to over a
period of time
piece by piece puzzle remember if we can
open well I think that's your biggest
part by far that's where the engine is
more important than any other thing that
we can we have an interesting interview
publishing tomorrow where we talk about
the oil situation it's very interesting
in with governor cuomo when there talk
about providing states like New York
with aid in the fourth stimulus package
wondering if you have any thoughts on
whether that aid should be tied to
infection rates whether states like New
York New Jersey that have been hardest
hit should receive more money and also
wondering if you have any thoughts on
Mayor Bill DeBlasio saying today that
he'd like to host ticker-tape parade of
sorts once this is all over to honor the
health care workers that sounds like a
good idea to me when it's all over it
sounds like a great idea they deserve it
their Warriors have done an incredible
job we mentioned briefly the state aid
we talked about that Governor Cuomo
myself and I agree may be over for 10
years most Republicans agree - and
Democrats and that's part of phase four
and I think infrastructure is going to
be a big part we have to rebuild our
country I mean you take a look where we
spend and we go over this all the time
with 8 trillion dollars in the Middle
East we want to rebuild our country and
that means our bridges or tunnels even
schools we're doing something with
schools we have to do our roadways
that what's happened we spent so much
money on other countries that don't even
that they don't appreciate it
ok they don't appreciate it we're gonna
spend money now on our country unreal
and it's gonna be our jobs then it's
gonna be our equipment
it's gonna be made much of it is going
to be made here hopefully at some point
all of its gonna be made here June mr.
president at that podium back on March
9th vice president pence said that over
a million tests had been distributed and
then he said in this exact quote love it
before the end of this week another 4
million tests will be distributed right
as you know now six weeks later we still
aren't at 4 million - I do love what a
statement with the testing ready are you
ready again I'll say it for the fifth
time we have tested more than any
country in the world and some of the
countries are very big ok more than any
country in the world we have one of the
most successful if you call mortality
rates because one person and I always
say that for you in particular one
person is too many but we've done very
well our testing if you add them all up
we've tested more now I don't know what
Mike Pence said but I'm sure he could
answer there's 4 million tests and we're
we're ready again
we've tested more than every country in
the world even keep repeating together
why so that's all I can say exactly if
you repeat it enough it does become the
truth
the China deal had to face one of this
China the the flight ban is still in
place how comforted are you that the
Chinese are not going to use invoke the
natural disaster Clause to just wait
before getting into yeah we're gonna say
look there's nobody ever been tougher on
China than me and that means for twenty
years you go back twenty years I
probably got elected at least partially
on the fact that I've been very tough I
said China's been ripping us off for
years I'd go into Michigan I'd go into
Pennsylvania make speeches unrelated to
being a politician I'd be invited I'd be
speaking to people which I like to do
because I love the people I love the
people of this country oh my god and I'd
make speeches nobody I'd say how did you
let this happen with China I even asked
the leaders of China how how did this
ever happen where our country loses tens
of billions of dollars a year and I
don't mean just tens take a look two
hundred billion three hundred billion
four hundred billion five hundred
billion dollars a year how did they ever
let anything like this happen now if you
look at this last year the deficit went
way down and I'm talking about even
before now it's much different but a lot
of things are happening great things
were happening except all of a sudden
out of nowhere came the invisible enemy
and we think we know where it came from
and we'll be talking about that probably
a lot but came the invisible enemy
there's been nobody tougher than me on
China determination and will do what I
can do better than anybody so yeah
please
Thomas told you that they think that the
virus escaped from a Chinese research
lab that it was a well I can't have US
intelligence agents told me I mean what
kind of a question is that do you think
I can't do you want me to tell you let
me tell you what they told me look they
told me plenty they told me plenty I
want to follow up one you said about the
small business program Harvard is going
to pay the money back how confident are
you that you can claw back money well I
said look I don't like when Harvard that
has I think forty billion dollar
endowment to some incredible amount of
money that Harvard gets this money
Harvard should pay that money back
I want Harvard to pay the money back
okay they won't do that then we won't do
something else they have to pay it back
I don't like it I don't like it this is
meant for workers this isn't meant for
one of the riches institutions not only
far beyond schools in the world they got
to pay it back I want them to pay it
back your Florida clubs have had to
furlough you're not allowed to have the
golf courses opened you can't have the
clubs opened can't have anything it's a
it's a big hotel in the resort and I
think it was probably 700 750 people so
you can't have anything opened and you
say what are we gonna do have full
payroll and have the whole place with
you no there's no income coming in
person who everyone's home and they're
supposed to be second Oman Florida you
can't use golf courses that one I'm not
sure I agree with you know you have
parks and golf courses where you have
open space but that's what it is so I
have others also that I have others in
different states have a lot of different
properties but again my children run
them and I love my children and I wish
them well
I look forward to comparing my numbers
to my children's numbers I think I'll do
better you have a father if you want to
say that well the closed property is
like you know you have to close him up
and then hopefully when things get
better we'll just open it up but you
can't have you know many hundreds of
employees standing around doing nothing
there's no customer you're not allowed
to have a lot of survey time up okay so
in some places in New Jersey strict New
York is strict and you have to do what
you have to do and it's too bad I feel
so badly when I say that I think that
it's a tough policy but I go by whatever
the policy that's a state policy in the
case of Florida try to reach out to him
to check on his condition
I just hope he's doing fine I mean I've
had a very good relationship with Kim
jong-un and that's to the benefit of the
country that's not a bad thing that's a
good thing and I'd like to see him be
well and we'll see how he does again I
don't know that the reports are true
line of succession as far as I know I
don't have a sim that bit of stuff it's
not it's not my it's believed that the
Kim jong-un's sister who's often with
him in public events would be the next
in line so with Georgia opening back up
you know things like tattoo parlor is
getting a massage
social dissing me there are some
creative ways but it seems very
difficult to do social distancing so do
you have a message for people in Georgia
who are soon gonna have a choice about
going at the hair salon or the nail
salon or getting that tattoo it's
they're not six feet apart and they're
not able to follow these social
distancing guidelines what's your
message to people in the state like
Georgia well we made it very clear in a
message to all of the American people
with opening up America again the
criteria that we wanted States to follow
those were careful criteria there were
only six they were carefully carefully
selected in conversations with
epidemiologists around the world and
with CDC to really pick things that
people could understand and use
platforms that people have utilized in
the past beautiful but it was built on
the premise that it needs to be
data-driven and it needs to protect
those who are most vulnerable and then
it went through the phases and the very
first thing it says in all phases all
individuals need to continue to wash
hands protect the vulnerable ensure the
safety of others but in phase one it
made it clear that social distancing was
absolutely key and I think it's on the
White House website and we asked every
American to read it and to use that as
their guidelines now we've also asked
governor's to create county level
information so that communities can see
the information and understand why they
may be different than a different county
so that it's very transparent and
understandable we've had a question here
a couple of days ago on a Jacksonville
Beach and Jacksonville is dramatically
different than Miami and I think that
was reflected in why Jacksonville had a
different set of information I think in
various how different it is on a per
capita basis though you know judge
anyone about their decision making what
I'm going to say is we were very clear
and what we
really believe protects the safety of
Americans and that is clearly laid up
laid out in the opening of America again
I have a question because we got Dana
from Tokyo an increase of cases and a
double of the cases in Singapore what
we've been you know looking a lot at
Europe after China and then we're back
into this area of the world here we're
not get about a plateau and then cases
going down any lessons to take out of
what we what's happening in this area in
Asia after I've been put our attention
somewhere else for ups or personal all
the lessons to be careful yeah there's
got to be very careful great I don't
want that to happen thing wouldn't
happen I think we stamp it out if it
does happen we're not gonna be doing any
mass closings I hope stamping so I think
we could you know I called some burning
embers and we put them out and I think
we've gotten very good at that but we'll
see but we don't want that to happen no
absolutely you guys are mr. president
what's the reopening happen we won't
need to go back into recalls II I don't
want to do that you don't want to do
that nobody in this room wants to do
that you look forward I think Brett very
soon and John sitting next to a lot of
your fellow reporters right the room
seems so empty this way but it's one of
those things yeah go ahead please
public support and if so USA Today all
just came out and found 80% of Americans
are supportive of the immigration halt
the temporary freeze did that have any
public support have any effect on your
decision-making Harris numbers yeah it's
a high number did not see that number I
heard there was a poll I'm sure there'll
be a lot of polls no look I think the
American people want to make sure that
they have jobs for the American people
not for people that come in in many
cases illegally into our country so
we're doing that I don't know what the
numbers are but I think just common
sense tells you that's where we should
be and that's where the how great is it
that she's not allowed to see it anymore
is another best our country back and I'm
telling you with all the things that
we're doing and infrastructure which we
desperately need it's gonna be an
incredible thing taking place I think
it's going to be a renaissance so we're
gonna have something that will be a lot
of people gonna go to work building
those roads and bridges and tunnels and
highways and all of the other things
we're gonna be building and broadband
for the Middle West I've been the
farmers haven't been treated fairly
let's face it the farmers have been
treated terribly he's gonna get a car
most of the internet so we're gonna take
care of that we're going to we're gonna
make them very happy so we'll see you
all tomorrow and we'll have some
interesting things to put out tonight
and I appreciate you being here and it's
an honor to have Britt bear here I think
you about used his slot a lot John use
that slot a lot get all this from
we want to have you back soon Danny's
looking very very strange okay
that is it for today a lot of
disinformation as as usual and on that
note I will also be rapping appreciate
you joining me remember
memberships likes positive emails no
anti-semitic comments always we want to
avoid those I'll see everybody tomorrow
you